now to the war in Ukraine president
zielinski has spoken with China's
president XI for the first time since
Russia's Invasion last year zielinski
says they had a meaningful conversation
meanwhile there is fierce fighting ahead
of Ukraine's expected spring offensive
but China may try to step in as
Peacemaker Charlie dagada is in Ukraine
new footage gives a rare look at the
Raging battle inside the eastern city of
Bak moons
Ukrainian soldiers take cover under
constant bombardment and gunfire
the most prolonged Battle of the war has
been costly for both sides a bloody
artillery shootout with tens of
thousands of casualties both intent on
inflicting as much damage as possible on
the other ahead of Ukraine's anticipated
counter-offensive
a large amount of Russia's most
combat-ready units have been deployed
around both boots as the deputy
Commander we're holding them here and
they cannot move to other directions
Ukraine's military has been showing off
some of the U.S supplied weapons ahead
of that offensive
while Russia has gone on the largest
recruitment Drive since the War Began
ad campaigns urge people to enlist with
slogans like defend the motherland and
you were a man be it
and in a conflict that has already come
at an horrific human cost with thousands
of civilians dead they're bracing here
for what's to come
as for that one hour phone call with the
Chinese president it may raise the
prospect of China as Peacemaker but
president zielinski said there can be no
peace at the expense of territorial
compromises Gail
Charlie dagada thank you we got it is
you're a man be it men at the table is
at an effective campaign you're a man be
it you could work it could work
impossible I mean I'm not rushing not
living in Russia but you know I'm glad I
assume they know what they're doing
there I'm glad we're sitting right here